I am sitting here with cake Hut this is
so cool we're at your uncommon James
party yeah did you imagine the brand
would get to this point you literally
started it from nothing yeah to this I
know it's been a wild ride it's crazy I
mean I really do have to pinch myself so
you know I mean I haven't even had on
common James for three years so it is
crazy
but it's been a ton of fun and I do feel
like because I'm so focused on the
future and just growing the brand it's
hard for me to take a step back
sometimes and just be like wow this is
actually really cool which I feel like
that's kind of my resolution this year
is to celebrate more you know more
successes so I'm trying to just
appreciate where we are and live in the
moment a little bit more and so I've
been so focused on you know 2021 and you
know what's what's ahead yeah you are in
season 3 of your show did you sign on
and think that we would get to season 3
I mean obviously I hoped that it was
good but you just never know exactly
nowadays TV is so weird you know it's so
interesting what works and what doesn't
work but you know it seems like people
love Jay yeah I love our dynamic and I
think because we're just being honest
you know we didn't start the show with
an agenda we weren't trying to put on
you know a show and be this character
we're just naturally being us and so I
think people can tell they realize that
it's authentic and that's what people
are really resonating with so yeah I'm
happy that we're still here season 3 I'm
waiting to hear about season 4 hopefully
that will happen I'm waiting - I love
that Jay looks like half the time he
looks like he doesn't want to be there
but then he's hilarious you know so it's
like I don't want to be there I think he
really loves it he's having fun with the
show yeah what would you say is the
biggest challenge obviously you come
from reality TV but it's kind of
understood that the hills in Laguna
Beach were more scripted obviously
watching the show you can tell it's very
it's very you it's very loose
what would you say is the biggest
challenge for yourself but like also J
for your marriage to have everything on
reality TV you know the hardest part is
that some days it's like you just don't
want to film like if maybe you're
fighting and then all of a sudden we've
to go and film this thing and it's like
okay we can talk about this later but we
have to go and put on a happy face right
now yeah because they're fine that can
be really challenging and yeah it's just
some pictures on the moon you know so
but we've done a good job of navigating
through it and I love filming with J
because he gets in he gets to the point
he's like boom and deliver my lines he's
like I know what the people want and so
he makes it easy and fun yeah has there
ever been a day that J was like okay the
cameras have to go like it's nap time
our kids don't have anymore so we're
past that phase he has taken off his
microphone and been like okay I'm done
you got it that's it
yeah and everyone's like okay great oh
my god not in like I'm like pissed off
me wait what you need it means I'm done
you don't have your kids on the show and
obviously like 2020 we're on social
media we show everything do you ever
have days where you're like oh this is
so cute I wish the world could see it or
you're just totally against it yeah I
mean of course there's moments around
like oh I think my kids look adorable
and I would love to share that part of
my role with everybody but I'm doing it
for my kids you know I just want to be
able to give them the freedom to make
that decision when they're old enough
yeah you know they may want no part of
entertainment and having their lives
exposed and that's perfectly fine so I
just want to let them make that decision
yeah if your kids do decide that they
want to do reality TV what is your
reaction like and go I'm your kid so you
know I think it's one of those things
that when they turn 18 great I will
support anything that you want to do
absolutely yeah but I think as long as
you're living under my roof I would say
no only because it's hard enough to be a
kid you know be
be a kid be a teenager so just focus on
that and if you really want to pursue a
career in entertainment that will be
there and so I would just really try to
have some open honest conversations with
them about that
yeah leaving your own life having real
friendships I know that was the subject
this season have you spoken to Kelly at
all
I have not oh my god yeah yeah yeah I
mean I don't have a lot to say about it
but yeah I haven't
unfortunately so it's just one of those
things does it put you on an island by
yourself do you feel like you can't
trust people even more now no I don't I
mean I think that you know I've always
sort of had a natural tendency not to
trust people initially you have to earn
my trust yeah that I think was from an
early age way before I was lonely gonna
beach or anything I think that's just
like innately Who I am and so you know
obviously what I've gone through with
some girlfriends it it stings but it
doesn't change me trusting people it's
more just that people can let you down
you know when you need someone to show
up sometimes they can't but you know I
think there's a lot to learn and grow
from every situation and that's just
what I am taking away from it what can I
learn from this and and grow from that
yeah are you still friends with people
from the hills do you watch the show now
so I haven't seen it because I don't
watch TV and I do want to support them
and guess I do love all of them I was
just with Heidi and Audrina and they
came to my man episode a very Cavallari
which was a ton of fun I talked to Brody
I talked to Stephen there's a lot of
people that I still speak to yeah and so
I want to watch The Hills in support I
don't have a TV in my bedroom yes and
not to make excuses but that's the one
time that I would watch TV actually my
kids go to bed and then where I go to
bed yeah and so I don't have a TV that's
like too bad I'm sorry I don't I don't
watch any TV yeah but maybe I'll
download on my phone and try to watch on
an airplane or
you know the tornado that hit Nashville
yeah did it affect you no luckily we
were very lucky but it's been crazy and
so we've all sort of banded together and
it just shows you how strong Nashville
really is and uncommon James I know that
all of my employees are volunteering
tomorrow we're actually shutting down
our fulfillment center tomorrow for the
day and everyone is going to go and
they're gonna help clean it up clean up
the city but obviously we know a lot of
people that were infected and it's just
so scary because we didn't know you know
was the middle of the night I thought it
was just supposed to rain I didn't know
that there was a tornado coming so yeah
we're very thankful that we were okay
but obviously you know the city's gone
through it right now it's crazy what's
next for you what's on the list is like
a tan going the beach what do you think
the virus not out there people are
scared I are out there let's share it
just at Tennessee which is no fun um
yeah but yeah we're still gonna go on
spring break you know obviously it's
important to be as healthy and safe as
you can but I don't think that we should
all stop living our lives to some degree
you know so we are gonna go on spring
break but um and then what's next you
know I'm just enjoying not filming right
now to be honest having some normalcy
with my life yeah
of course celebrating on common James
and little James tonight three elections
we have a big partnership with a
sunglass company in the spring or I
should say early summer which I'm
excited about and then we're gonna
launch Demi fine jewelry in the fall so
14 karat 14 karat gold-plated sterling
silver and real diamonds you know I'm
very very excited about busy lady well
it's a pleasure talking to you thank you
for having us here this is gonna be a
pop and party you gotta stay on yeah
well I mean when you look like that man
okay cake thank you for having me